j'ai pas fait ça pour profiter de
l'occasion parce qu'on est en
négociation j'ai fait ça parce que c'est
un problème qui est important c'est
bâtiment leçons des bâtiments publics
ça fait des années qu'on laisse les
écoles se détériorer je le fais parce
que c'est mon milieu de travail et que
je veux et travailler et rester en santé
je le fais parce que c'est le milieu de
vie des enfants et je considère qu'ils
ont droit un milieu de vie sain bon si
je travaille dans une école la
commission scolaire un petit peu les
deux rôles maman et et enseignants puis
oui c'est des choses qu'on observe
effectivement dans les écoles c'est sûr
qu'il faut de l'argent mais qui commence
à en mettre un peu de l'argent pour
faire des rénovations
parce que c'est c'est nos enfants qui
vont être dans la lah les problèmes
c'est comme toute rouillée dans les
quasi la même chose c'est comme très
sale